welcome to you my listening friend I'm
delighted you've joined us this special
q a session with me is my friend Pastor
B GoGo who will assist me in answering
your questions and I hope under the
guidance of the spirit of God we will
say something that will Enlighten your
understanding my pastor welcome
thank you
plus the questions for you today one of
the first ones is about judas's career
yes and someone wonders did he play a
role in our Salvation because if he
didn't betray Jesus how would salvation
have come our way interesting question
I've never heard it before Judas did not
play a role in our salvation but he had
he played a role in part of the drama
that was the Life of Christ particularly
towards the end of his life the Bible
predicted in Psalm 41 verse 9. here's
what that verse says yea my own familiar
friend in whom I trusted which did eat
of my bread hath lifted up his heel
against me the expression lift up the
hill simply means to deceive or to
betray the Bible predicted that someone
would betray Christ it did not predict
that Judas would betray Christ he made
that a personal choice but the scripture
prophecy must come to pass so if Judas
had not betrayed Christ someone else
would have because the Bible said he had
to be betrayed but the Bible did not God
did not pre-select Judas to betray
Christ this was his own choice but
someone had to so if Judas had not done
that someone would have done it because
the word of God must come to pass but
played no role in our Salvation not at
all that role was played by Christ the
spirit and the father
thank you prophecy had to be fulfilled
and judas's own choice led him into that
thank you and the other questions about
somebody who is new to the faith
they live with an elderly person who
plays loud music that he finds to be
destructive in his personal work as a
Christian and he wonders should he just
pray or is there anything else he can do
to help him as a young Christian
the Bible says in Romans 12 verse 18
as much as if it be possible as much as
lieth in you live peaceably with all men
the Christian will from time to time
find himself or herself in unfavorable
circumstances whether you're on a plane
you're on a bus you're on a train you're
in the supermarket you're wherever you
may be a hospital there will be things
in the environment that challenge your
spiritual life what I recommend to this
person is to pray about idiots take it
to God the person may get some
headphones listen to Spiritual music
listen to the Bible being read
find ways to deal with this challenge
but the person has to do it in such a
way that Christ is reflected there are
no exceptions for reflecting Christ in
the Christian's life so when dealing
with a challenging situation we still
have to do so in a way that reflects
Christ and that very attitude may have
an effect on the personal who's
contributing to the unpleasant
environment that's my counsel to that
person
amen maintain a christ-like a spirit a
demeanor okay and we do have an uh
brother or a sister from Nigeria who has
a question about prayer and the question
is is it okay to pray with the alligator
paper
alligator Pepper when I first heard that
expression I had to go to the YouTube to
find out what it was I had never heard
of alligator pepper I was a little
surprised as to what I discovered when
praying you do not need props
not at all
Jesus tells us in John 14 14 if he shall
ask anything in my name I will do it so
we pray in the name of Jesus in first
John chapter 4 chapter 5 verse 14 and
this is the confidence that we have in
him that if we ask anything according to
his will he heareth us so we pray in the
name of Jesus we pray according to the
will of God
Mark 11 24 verily I say unto you if ye
shall say to this mountain be thou
removed and be cast into the sea and
shall not doubt and so we pray in faith
that's Mark 11 23 and 24.
Psalm 66 Verse 18 if I regard iniquity
in my heart the Lord will not hear me I
must confess my sins Proverbs 28 verse 9
he that turneth away his ear from
hearing the law even his prayer shall be
an Abomination we must not disregard
God's directions what he requires of us
and so there are conditions for God
answering prayer but nowhere in the
Bible is it stated you need a prop not
alligator pepper you don't even need a
rosary as some Catholics do and I used
to be a Catholic I used to use a rosary
we do not need props we go to God we
pray in the name of Jesus as far as
possible according to his will as we
know it but the Bible tells us if he
abide in me and my words abide in you he
shall ask what ye will and it shall be
done unto you the diligent study of
God's word educates us as to what God's
will is for us but no one needs to pray
using alligator Pepper or any such thing
we pray in the name of Jesus Christ The
Spirit guides us we pray in faith
according to God's Will and we obey God
First John 3 22 and whatever we ask we
receive of him because we keep his
Commandments and do those things which
are pleasing in his sight you do not
need alligator Pepper or any such thing
thank you and another believer who is
new to the faith wonders of svara's
preparation for Sabbath is concerned
when it comes to their personal Journey
they've been reading the book of Exodus
and they are studying about the Sabbath
and what we need to do to be ready for
the day of the Lord and he wonders or
she wonders is it okay to rewarm my food
on Sabbath yes
the 70 Adventist Church believes it is
fine and we're based that on counsel
from our special servant Ella white
Child Guidance page 532 paragraph two it
is not necessary to eat cool food let
the food be warmed the Bible tells us
don't cook on Sabbath it does not forbid
warming the food it's fine to warm the
food very cold food should not be eaten
very hot food should not be eaten warm
food should be eaten it's best for the
health
thank you and we still have someone here
who um
in listening to one of your summons
entitled what is probation has a
question for you and
he believes that the love of God lasts
forever and how can probation close in
somebody's lifetime if God's love lasts
forever doesn't it last as long as life
lasts as long as there is God there will
be love
but God has a certain degree of patience
with sin
this is called Divine forbearance it has
limits we see that very dramatically
demonstrated in the story of the flood
in Genesis 6 from verse 1 and it came to
pass when men began to multiply on the
face of the Earth and daughters were
born unto them that the sons of God saw
the daughters of men that they were fair
and they took them wives of always their
choice and the Lord said my spirit shall
not always strive with man clearly there
comes a time when the spirit stops
convicting and stops pleading when that
happens probation has ended God said but
his day shall be 120 years God gave the
antediluvians
120 years as Noah built the ark and Noah
preached when that time expired Genesis
7 verse 16 the Bible says the Lord shut
Noah into the ark when God did that the
probation of those on the outside had
closed yet God's love was still
continuing the fact God's love does not
alter the fact he's a God of Justice a
loving God sent the flood a loving God
destroys Sodom and Gomorrah by fire a
loving God got tired of the disobedient
Israelites and sent Nebuchadnezzar to
destroy the city Daniel 1 and 2 actually
tell us chapter 1 verses 1 and 2 God
gave Jerusalem into Nebuchadnezzar's
hand a loving God destroyed his City
Jerusalem 30 years after Christ went
back to Heaven God's love does not
cancel his justice so yes his love is
constant but his patience with sin is
limited there is such a thing as
probation so the Bible urges us today if
you will hear his voice Harden not your
heart
amen
we do have a few questions on the Holy
Spirit
and one of them is as far as is he God
and if so okay
[Music]
these questions grant us wisdom you've
promised in James 1 verse 5 if any lack
wisdom let him ask of God we ask you the
God grant us wisdom because those
listening are people whom you love and
you desire to have them correctly
instructed so guide us I pray in Jesus
name Amen in John chapter 3 verse 8
listen to what Jesus says and we'll read
microscopically
the wind bloweth where it listeth
and though here is the sound thereof but
can't not tell whence it come with it
whence it cometh or with it goeth so is
everyone that is born of the spirit
Jesus attributes conversion as the work
of the spirit the new birth is the work
of the spirit from the very lips of
Christ this is salvation the conversion
may be called the new birth it is also
justification by faith that instant act
that takes place when a person puts all
of his or her faith in Christ as a
savior instantly that person is
Justified that person is converted that
is the work of the spirit of God only a
Divine being can do that in Isaiah 45
verse 22 the Bible says look unto me and
be saved all the ends of the Earth for I
am God and there is none else meaning
only God can save in verse 18 of Isaiah
45 the Bible said for thus said the Lord
that created the heavens God himself
that formed the Earth and made it he
hath established it he created it not in
vain he formed it to be inhabited I am
the Lord and there's none else only God
can create so only God can create Isaiah
45 18 only God can save Isaiah 45 22 but
we know from Christ's words in John 3 8
it is the spirit that brings about the
New Birth that is salvation only a
Divine being can do that
Psalm 104 verse 29 of verse 29 and 30
thou sendeth forth thy Spirit they are
created the spirit can create the spirit
can save the spirit must be divine
mm-hmm
let me say something else sorry
in First Corinthians 2 verses 9 and 10
but I have not seen neither ear heard
neither hath entered into the heart of
man the things which God has prepared
for them that love him but God hath
revealed them to us by his spirit for
the spirit searcheth all things what are
the all things the Deep things of God
the spirit of God knows everything God
knows the spirit of God must be a Divine
being
amen and a follow-up to that would be as
far as the holy spirit being the
representative of Jesus Christ and the
question thereby is how can he be a
representative of Christ is he God the
spirit is a representative of Christ and
of God
but so too is Jesus Jesus is a
representative of the father or an agent
if you prefer that term in Ephesians
chapter 3 verse 9 the Bible says and to
make all men see what is the Fellowship
of the mystery which from the beginning
of the world have been hidden God who
created All Things by Jesus Christ
Christ is an agent of the father in
creation he's an agent of the father in
Salvation the spirit is an agent of the
father and of the son because in John 14
26 the father sends the spirit in John
15 26 Jesus sends the spirit so yes he's
an agent of the father and of the son
but his distinct being as is Christ who
is also an agent of the father so the
fact that the spirit is an agent does
not make the spirit less of a
personality because Christ is also an
agent of the Father the spirit is an
agent of the father or representative so
is Christ that's why Christ could say he
that have seen me have seen the father
yes the spirit is a representative or an
agent but so too is Jesus Christ they
are separate individual entities now
Ellen White our special Prophet tells us
in evangelism page 316 paragraphs 5 6
and 7. the spirit is a person as much as
God is a spertle and in page 617
paragraph three of evangelism she writes
this we are to cooperate with the three
great great powers of Heaven the Father
the Son and the Holy Ghost and they will
work with us towards our salvation
amen and still still on them
Holy Spirit there is the question on the
doctrine of the Trinity is it biblical
or is it demonic oh that's a serious
question the adoption of the Trinity is
absolutely biblical
and I hope no one will call it demonic
if you don't believe in it just say I
don't believe it but don't go as far as
to say this is demonic
in Matthew 12 reading for verse 22 then
was brought unto him one possessed with
the devil blind and dumb and he healed
him in so much that the Blind and Dumbo
spake and saw and all the people were
amazed and said is not this the son of
David but when the Pharisees heard it
they said this fellow doth not cast out
Devils but by me Elizabeth the prince of
devils the Pharisees attributed the work
of Christ to the devil or the work of
the spirit through Christ because Christ
did his good works by the power of the
spirit acts 10 38 it was by the spirit's
power that Christ did what he did his
miracles the Pharisees said this is the
work of the devil this is demonic this
is a very serious charge because of this
Jesus said in verse 31 and verse 32
wherefore I say unto you all manner of
sin and blasphemy shall be forgiven unto
men but the blasphemy against the Holy
Ghost shall not be forgiven unto man by
the way we have two distinct
Personalities in that verse you can
blaspheme the son or blaspheme the Holy
Spirit verse 32 whosoever therefore
shall speak anything against the son of
man it shall be forgiven him
but whosoever speaketh against the Holy
Ghost it shall not be forgiven to him
neither in this world neither in the
world to come and so we have two
distinct personalities but on the point
of the doctrine being demonic Jesus
tells us if you blaspheme the Holy Ghost
there's no forgiveness
to call the holy ghost or the work of
the Holy Ghost the work of the devil is
the height of blasphemy against the Holy
Ghost
to say there's no Holy Ghost is to say
you're not a child of God because the
Bible says if any man hath not the
spirit of Christ he's none of his Romans
8 verse 16 the spirit beareth witness
with our spirit that we are the children
of God without the spirit of God you
cannot be identified as a child of God
the holy spirit is a Divine being as
much as the father and the son they are
one in essence they are different in
persons it is not a demonic teaching it
is a Biblical teaching please my dear
friend if you don't believe it just say
I don't believe it but do not describe a
Biblical teaching as demonic
and thank you very much so the term
Trinity may not be in the Bible but the
teaching is in the Bible sex is not in
the Bible either but no one will deny
the Bible deals with it amen
and our last question is from um one of
our the viewers who uh wonders why
didn't the disciples baptize in the name
of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit just like Jesus commanded they
did baptize the name of the Father the
Son of the holy spirit is just not
written out the list all three but they
did baptize because they obeyed The
Words of Christ because let's let's go
to if you go to Genesis 14 let me show
you a feature of biblical writing
Genesis 14 verse 1. now we came to pass
in the days of amrifel king of China
Arya king of Elisa kedro Leoma king of
Elam and title king of Nations that
these made war with Bera king of Sodom
and with bersha king of Gomorrah shinab
king of admir and shameeba king of
zeboim and the king of Bella we have
Sodom Gomorrah admissible man and Bella
five cities of the plane which were
burned up when God destroyed Sodom and
Gomorrah and the cities of the plane now
but those five are almost never
mentioned
the Bible usually just says Sodom and
Gomorrah but meaning those are the three
as well this is very clear from the book
of Jude
verse 7 even as Sodom and Gomorrah and
the cities about them
they're not mentioned but and the cities
above them now they're listed in Genesis
4 verses 14 verse 2 but they're not
listed almost anywhere else it's always
Sodom and Gomorrah they represent the
other three because the verse says even
as Sodom and Gomorrah and the cities
about them in like manner another
example of this kind of writing Psalm
106 verse 17. the Earth opened and
swallowed up death and and covered the
company of a Byram Bible students know
three men rebelled against the authority
of Moses Korah death and a Byron the
psalmist only mentions too but we have
to fill in the blanks and put Korah
because in number 16 from verse 1 now
Korah the son of Izar the son of kohath
the son of Levi and dathan and a Byram
so we have the three but only two are
mentioned in Psalm 106 but we know what
the psalmist includes by implication
Cora even though his name is not there
when the Rich Young Ruler came to Christ
in Matthew 19 I think it is but
certainly in Luke 18 what must I do to
be saved Jesus said thou knows the
Commandments do not commit adultery do
not kill do not steal do not bear false
witness honor thy father and thy mother
he only mentioned five of the ten are we
to understand Christ disregarded the
other five no by mentioning even one the
reader would know immediately he's
referring to the Ten Commandments
another example a modern example we're
recording in the state of Minnesota
right now if I were to hear someone
please identify this state and tell me
what state it is I'll give you some
cities and I would say El Paso Dallas
Houston just by saying Dallas the person
would say Texas I do not have to list
all the cities in Texas and so
frequently the Bible writers do not give
an entire list they give a partial list
expecting that the readers would fill in
the blank and so when we read in Acts 19
verse 5 to 7 that Paul baptized 12
disciples in the name of Jesus we have
to understand the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Ghost even though the
entire list was not given it's a feature
of Bible writing
amen and that brings us to the end of
our questions today thank you Pastor all
right welcome my pleasure my listening
friends I hope you were blessed I hope
you learned some little thing I hope you
were blessing to you by the way we try
to answer your questions from the word
of God from time to time we'll take some
questions we cannot answer all questions
we look at them by prayer and by
conviction we choose some and we answer
I realize your question is personal to
you but we cannot answer every possible
question but I hope you'll continue to
study God's word because the spirit of
God has been promised to us to guide us
into Truth Bible study is fellowship
with God do not allow other people to
study the Bible for you you study it
fellowship with God and with angels
because in Daniel 8 an angel was
commanded to teach Daniel or help Daniel
understand when you study God's word you
are fellowshiping with God and with
angels so please do not give up that
privilege may the Lord bless you and we
hope to see you again my pastor thank
you and God bless you thank you
thank you thank you